>> Tucker: MAJOR TWIST
TONIGHT INVOLVING LEAKED
VIDEO OF AMY ROBACH TALKING
ABOUT THE NETWORK SHE WORKS
FOR KILLING THE JEFFREY
EPSTEIN STORY.
NOW A TV PRODUCER WHO
RECENTLY LEFT ABC NEWS FOR
CBS HAS BEEN FIRED.
HUH.
A SHORT TIME AGO SHE SPOKE
WITH NEWS ANCHOR MEGYN
KELLY.
FOX NEWS CHIEF BREAKING NEWS
CORRESPONDENT TRACE
GALLAGHER IS HELPING TO PUT
THE PIECES OF THIS FAIRLY
COMPLICATED BUT INTERESTING
STORY TOGETHER TONIGHT.
TRACE?
>> TUCKER, THE FORMER ABC
NEWS PRODUCER ACCUSED OF
LEAKING THE AMY ROBACH
RECORD SOMETHING 25-YEAR-OLD
ASHLEY BIANCA.
WHEN IDENTIFIED EXECUTIVES
AT NEW EMPLOYER CBS HAD
IMMEDIATELY FIRED HER.
DURING EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW
WITH OUR FORMER COLLEAGUE
MEGYN KELLY, BIANCO SELLS
SHE IS NOT THE LEAKER.
WATCH.
>> IT WASN'T ME.
YOU KNOW, I'M NOT THE
WHISTLEBLOWER.
I'M SORRY TO ABC, BUT THE
LEAKER IS STILL INSIDE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT -- I
NEVER DID ANY OF THAT I MAY
HAVE ACCESSED IT, BUT I
NEVER, NEVER LEAKED IT.
I NEVER SHOWED IT TO ANYONE.
I DIDN'T TALK ABOUT THE
SITUATION OUTSIDE THE
COMPANY.
>> BIANCO ACKNOWLEDGES AS
PART OF HER JOB SHE RECORDED
AMY ROBACH'S RANT ABOUT HOW
EXECUTIVES BURIED HER
EXPLOSIVE REPORT ABOUT CHILD
RAPIST JEFFREY EPSTEIN.
HERE'S PART OF THAT.
WATCH.
>> SHE WAS IN HIDING 12
YEARS.
WE CONVINCED HER TO COME OUT
AND TALK TO US.
IT WAS UNBELIEVABLE WHAT WE
HAD CLINTON.
WE HAD EVERYTHING.
I TRIED FOR THREE YEARS TO
GET IT ON TO NO AVAIL AND
NOW IT'S ALL COMING OUT.
NEW REVELATIONS AND I
FREAKING HAD ALL OF IT.
I AM SO PISSED RIGHT NOW.
>> ACTUALLY BIANCO SAYS SHE
TOLD HER MANAGER WHAT ROBACH
SAID BUT THAT PRETTY MUCH
EVERYONE IN THE OFFICE HAD
ALREADY HEARD IT.
BUT BIANCO SAYS SHE NEVER
HEARD OF PROJECT VERITAS
UNTIL THEY RELEASED THAT
TAPE.
AND SHE NEVER SPOKE WITH
PROJECT VERITAS FOUNDER
JAMES O'KEEFE AND O'KEEFE
TODAY CONFIRMED IT.
IN FACT LATE TODAY PROJECT
VERITAS PUBLISHED A LETTER
FROM THE ABC INSIDE HIS OR
HER THEY SAY LEAKED THE
TAPE.
THAT PERSON WRITES TO ABC
NEWS QUOTING HERE I LIKE
MANY ARE AT A LOSS OF WORDS
HOW THIS HAS BEEN HANDLED.
INSTEAD OF ADDRESSING THIS
HEAD ON LIKE THE COMPANY HAS
IN THE PAST IT.
HAS BEEN SPUN INTO A MIFINGS
SEEK AND DESTROY.
INNOCENT PEOPLE THAT HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO DO
WITH THIS ARE BEING HUNTED
DOWN AS IF IT WERE ALL A
SPORT.
AND ASHLEY BIANCO JUST WANTS
HER CAREER BACK.
LOOK.
>> HOW MANY DAYS HAD YOU
BEEN AT CBS?
>> FOUR DAYS, YOU KNOW.
AND I BEGGED, I PLEADED.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT I HAD
DONE WRONG.
AND I JUST, YOU KNOW, I
WASN'T EVEN GIVE THE
PROFESSIONAL COURTESY TO
DEFEND MYSELF, YOU KNOW.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT I HAD
BEEN ACCUSED OF.
IT WAS HUMILIATING.
IT WAS DEVASTATING.
>> WE REACHED OUT TO BOTH
ABC NEWS AND CBS NEWS FOR
COMMENT, SO FAR NO RESPONSE.